bonjour à toutes et à tous je mets
trompait jamais trempé la dernière fois
parce que je vous ai dit que j'avais pas
que c'était fini les cours sur les
terres apside et en fait non je me suis
rappelé qu effectivement en 2018 jeu
donnait un cours sur l'évolution de
landau termine donc l'évolution du
métabolisme à sang chaud chez les terres
apside et que c'est un cours que j'ai
arrêté de donner en fait parce que là on
a dû réduire drastiquement le nombre
d'heures que de court qu'on devait
donner aux étudiants pour diverses
raisons
et du coup ce cours là complètement
sauté au fait au lieu de au lieu de
donner un cours spécifique sur leur de
terminer en fait je me suis mis à à
saupoudrer en fait les idées qu'il y
avait dans ce cours là dans le reste du
cours sur l'évolution des thérapeutiques
mais du coup du coup c'est un cours que
je donnais autrefois mais que je ne
donne plus mais je pense que c'est la
très bonne occasion là d'en parler de
parler de l'évolution de leurs de
terminer donc de déterrer un peu secours
alors ils du coup il y aura peut-être
quelques imagerie un peu vieillotte
dedans je sais pas mais bon on verra
bien si certaines choses ont mal vieilli
ou pas je vous le ferai savoir je les ai
jetés j'ai quand même gelé quand même
regarder une fois avant de vous leur
donnez secours parce que quand même je
suis pas je suis un peu responsable dans
les choses que je peux j'essaie de vous
apprendre mais mais effectivement il ya
des choses qui auront peut-être un peu
mal vieilli mais on verra bien en tout
cas c'est à la cour que j'aimais
beaucoup donné parce que l'évolution de
landau terme et c'est quand même une
chose que j'étudie assez activement et
donc il ya une partie assez notable de
ceux de secours qui ce qui est
directement reliée à mes propres
recherches
voilà donc donc j'espère que ça va vous
plaire en tout cas en tout cas moi ça me
fait plaisir de vous le donner comme
tous ces cours d'ailleurs on commence
déjà par une petite introduction et sève
à l'évolution de landau termine donc
l'évolution du métabolisme à sang chaud
on verra après ce que ça cache commencez
pas déjà tapé dans les commentaires que
l'on de terminer pas le métabolisme sang
chaud vous en faites pas on ira dans les
détails on ira dans les détails au
moment voulu
pour l'instant reste général donc
l'évolution de landau terme ils veulent
c c'est quelque chose donc qui a eu lieu
deux fois une fois dans la lignée des
mammifères donc les synapses ide et une
fois dans la lignée des oiseaux donc les
théropodes et il se trouve que dans la
lignée des théropodes est bien là cette
transition depuis un métabolisme à sang
froid jusqu'à un métabolisme à son show
elle commence à être relativement bien
comprise et relativement bien documenté
notamment par le registre fossile à
savoir que le registre fossile
il donne quand même deux indices direct
de l'évolution du métabolisme à sang
chaud les théropodes le premier c'est
l'évolution des plumes donc de la
couverture des plumes et on a notamment
ses plumes filamenteuses qu'on retrouve
chez tous les théropodes donc qui est
qu'ils sont qui ressemble beaucoup à une
fourrure et qui donc sur des indicateurs
assez fort de l'évolution d'un
métabolisme à sang chaud chez ces
théropodes et on a aussi l'évolution de
de la couvaison donc on a un registre
fossile de dinosaure en train de couver
leurs oeufs et 7 couvaison elle peut
difficilement ce interprété autrement
que si on imagine que déjà de base c'est
théropodes étaient était à sang chaud
je veux dire protéger les yeux c'est
peut-être une quelque chose mais c'est
quelque chose que tout le monde sait
faire sans avoir pourtant pour autant à
s'asseoir dessus
voilà c'est ce que je veux dire protéger
les halls et les tortues le fond en
enterrant leur zèle et il ya des oiseaux
qui s'appelle les mégapoles qui
enterrent leurs yeux aussi enfin je veux
dire c'est c'est quelque chose qui se
fait depuis que l'oeuf existe c'est à
dire depuis toujours depuis que les
tétrapodes existent ils pondent des
oeufs et je veux dire bon bah pourquoi
pourquoi s'asseoir dessus quoi si c'est
pour les protéger et pour les protéger
on savait déjà le faire avant donc la
couvaison c'est quand même un indicateur
très directe de l'évolution d'un
métabolisme à sang chaud
ce qui ne veut pas dire que les
théropodes se sont mis à couvert leur
jeu dès qu'ils ont eu le sang chaud ils
ont pu il ya pu y avoir un temps de
latence entre l'évolution du sang chaud
et la couv
mais la couvaison en elle-même est un
indicateur direct de d'un métabolisme à
sang chaud donc on a le registre fossile
de ces protoplumes de ces filaments plus
mr chez les théropodes et peut-être même
celle ancêtres en commun de tous les
avais métatarse à lien c'est à dire
dinosaures et ptérosaures inclus
peut-être qu'ils avaient déjà une
couverture de ce qu'on appelle des pics
nos fibres c'est à dire des filaments
des plumes filamenteuses plus entre
guillemets puisque c'est si on fait
l'hypothèse d'homologie mais il y en a
qui sont pas d'accord évidemment mais
bon bref c'est voilà donc on a ce
registre fossile de ces filaments et on
a le registre fossile de la couvaison
qui sont quand même tous des des non
seulement qui sont relativement complet
mais qui en plus sont des registres
fossiles relativement complet mais qui
en plus sont des indicateurs direct de
l'évolution de l'ordre de ternir en plus
de tous les indices comme l'histologie
etc dont on ne parlera pas dans le cadre
des dinosaures mais que l'on vous pouvez
vous pouvez très facilement trouver des
contenus qui vous expliqueront
l'évolution de landau termine chez les
dinosaures
ça c'est absolument pas un problème et y
compris en français ce n'est absolument
pas un problème par contre celle été
rapide alors là on a pas du tout de
registre fossile de la fourrure chez les
thérapies dont on en parlera du registre
fossile de la fourrure dans les
thérapies site vous verrez que on m'en
fait le tour mais alors très très vite
donc le registre fossile de la couvaison
celle été rapide
le voici devant vos yeux ébahis il
s'agit d'un crâne d'un adulte enfin d'un
subadulte de dictons préservé avec ici
un bébé dicte aux dons ici que vous
voyez là et que vous allez voir se
déployer devant vos yeux dans dans
quelques secondes
donc voilà et c'est la totalité du
registre fossile de la couvaison celle
été rapide ce n'est même pas un cas de
couvaison en réalité c'est juste il ya
un crâne d'adultes avec un juvénile
enfin en l'occurrence il ya même deux
juvénile la danse jusque le deuxième
juvénile
n'est pas représenté parce qu'il n'est
pas très joli mais voilà le la totalité
du registre fossile delà des soins
parentaux sont trouve devant vos yeux
on a plusieurs autres cas de possible
soins parentaux mais ils sont contestés
donc et puis là c'est vraiment le seul
cas qu'on a en fait de d'un adulte avec
un bébé dans un terrier en fait donc
dans un possible ce qui serait
l'équivalent dany pour un terreau apside
en fait donc on a un adulte avec deux
bébés d'ailleurs pas un deux bébés dans
un terrier
mais il faut bien l'admettre que c'est
que c'est peu de chose quoi il faut bien
admettre que c'est peu de chose et que
ça n'a dit qu absolument pas un
comportement de couvaison en fait donc
ça n'indique absolument pas que les
dicte aux dons étaient à 100 ch et donc
le sang chaud de kessé de camp que c'est
que ça a évolué chez été rapide bas on
va le voir aujourd'hui
et puis vous allez être plutôt déçus par
la réponse c'est aussi le sait aussi une
autre des raisons pour laquelle je ne
donne plus aux courses et parce que la
réponse à la question quand est ce que
le sang chaud a évolué et est assez
décevante et que du coup les étudiants
en fait c'est pas que les étudiants
étaient déçus mais en fait du coup ils
savaient pas quoi apprendre de cette
présentation parce que les preuves sont
tellement contradictoires qu'au final
les étudiants ça les perturbe de pas
savoir quoi apprendre quoi en tirer en
fait de cette présentation
bon bref donc le sang chaud déjà pour
bien commencer une discussion sur quand
est ce que le sang chaud et évoluer va
falloir établir ce que ça veut dire que
d'avoir le sang chaud et pour ça on a ce
tableau magnifique tableau qui vous
montre donc les quatre métabolisme les
quatre thermo physiologie qui existe qui
existent enfin du moins con qu'on
accepte couramment mes envies évidemment
si vous commencez à pigna chercher dans
les détails vous allez en trouver
d'autres mais les quatre grands thermes
au métabolisme ses lecteurs et remis
landau thermie la peau et qui a été
remis et lomé au termine donc l'hecto
termine c'est quand la température de
votre corps dépend de la température
extérieure exemple le lézard le lézard
est obligé de se mettre au soleil pour
se réchauffer
landau termine c'est qu'entre votre
température intérieure est indépendante
de la température extérieure c'est quand
votre corps reste à 37° 5 si vous êtes
un mammifère 42° si vous êtes un oiseau
donc ça c'est les mammifères et les
oiseaux donc c'est ce qu'on appellerait
généralement le sang chaud mais à ça
donc à 7 ans de permis il faut ajouter
quand même une nuance et cette nuance
c'est la peau y piloter remis et lomé au
thermique la peau et kg termine c'est
quand la température de votre corps
varie donc un ectothermes est
généralement politi le terme à savoir
qu'un ectothermes donc quelqu'un dont la
température dépend de l'extérieur va
avoir un animal dont la température
dépend de l'extérieur va avoir la
température de son corps qui va varier
en fonction du jour et de la nuit et des
saisons fatalement vu que sa température
dépendent l'extérieur mais un mammifère
peut avoir aussi une température qui
varient température du corps qui varient
tous les mammifères sont généralement en
moyenne plus froid en hiver qu'en été
mais il ya des mammifères qui sont
extrêmement froid en hiver notamment
tous ceux qui y gouverne comme par
exemple le bush baby que vous voyez là
les ours pour prendre plus proche de
chez nous les ours quand ils hibernent
et ben alors la température de leur
corps chute à 20 degrés je crois donc
leur métabolisme se ralentit donc ils
sont peu utile au terme malgré le fait
qu'ils sont capables de produire leur
propre chaleur ils ne le font pas tout
le temps voilà et d'un autre côté vous
avez les hommes et aux termes et chez
les hommes et aux termes là vous allez
avoir une température du corps constante
alors ça peut être parce que vous êtes
en d'autres termes est actif toute
l'année comme nous par exemple on
produit notre chaleur en continu alors
même si en hiver notre température
diminue un peu en moyenne elle reste
relativement constante au cours de
l'année et même pendant la nuit
par contre il y a des esclops terme dont
la température du corps restent
relativement constante vous allez penser
notamment les arts tropicaux les lézards
tropicaux y vivent dans un environnement
où la température ne change pas donc au
final pourquoi leur température de corps
changerait c'est la raison pour laquelle
par exemple on voit pas de cernes de
croissance dans les palmiers
les palmiers y vivent dans des régions
qui sont tropicale donc ya pas de cernes
de croissance dans le tronc des palmiers
puisqu'ils vivent dans des régions
tropicales
oui enfin c'est un exemple c'est
peut-être même pas un bon exemple mais
voilà vous voyez l'idée quoi et ses
essais lézarde du cou qui vivent dans
les régions tropicales
vous pouvez faire des coupes dans les
eaux autant que vous voulez vous ne
verrez pas de cerner de croissance
dedans parce qu'il n'ya pas d'arrêt de
la croissance pendant l'hiver vu qu'il
ya pas d'hiver donc voilà ils sont
nommés au terme et ça si vous si vous
êtes quelqu'un qui a acquis mais sa foi
dans les fermes de croissance comme
étant un indice fort d'en doter remis
basset faut en fait vous c'est un indice
fort domeo terminé pas forcément dans
d'autres termes ils n'ont pas forcément
de ce qu'on appelle le sang chaud le
sang qui reste chaud tout le temps et
d'un autre côté vous avez aussi les
hommes et au terme donc qu'ils sont à
sang froid ectothermes mais qui du coup
ont une température qui reste constante
parce qu'ils sont trop gros pour
refroidir
donc à chaque fois que leurs muscles
bouge ça produit de la chaleur mais
comme ils ont un bon accord qui est
beaucoup trop gros pour que cette
chaleur s'évacue ce que je vous rappelle
que la chaleur s'évacue par la surface
et que la surface augmente au carré
alors que le volume lui augmente au cube
donc c'est donc vous avez un volume de
corps qui se réchauffe avec une surface
de corps qui elle par contre se rétrécit
au fur et à mesure que le volume
augmente comme le volume augmente plus
vite que la surface en fait les corps
qui sont très gros vont produire
énormément de chaleur qui auront de
moins en moins de surface pour se
reproduire pour se refroidir
on se reproduire se refroidir donc plus
un animal est gros plus il produit de la
chaleur à chaque fois qu'ils bougent
mais plus cette chaleur va aussi être
retenus par le cor par le volume du
corps parce qu'il y aura
proportionnellement moins de surface
pour dispenser cette chaleur donc les
gros animaux
même s'ils sont à sang froid vont être
techniquement homéo terme comme les
tortues luth par exemple dans les
animaux moderne et comme on s'attend à
ce que ce soit le cas pour les
sauropodes les sauropodes qu'ils aient
été ectothermes ou en de termes de toute
façon était certainement homéo terme
parce qu'ils sont juste gigantesque
voilà donc et c'est là aussi où on place
généralement la maiso termine enfin non
dans le cas des sauropodes on parle de
gigue en termine donc une ome au
thermique qui est dû au fait qu'ils sont
gigantesques
les sauropodes était probablement
d'ailleurs à sang froid enfin
ectothermes par nécessité c'est à dire
que même si leurs ancêtres avaient été à
sang chaud pour atteindre la taille que
les sauropodes matin ils ont été
peut-être obligé de faire marche arrière
sur leur terme en physiologie et
redevenir à sang froid
simplement parce que leur volume était
tellement gigantesques que de toute
façon ça aurait été un désavantage
d'être en d'autres termes
donc si ça se trouve quand on parle des
sauropodes quand on parle de la gigue en
terminer ce repos dont on parle en fait
d'un animal qui était à sang chaud
primitivement et il ya de plus en plus
de preuves aujourd'hui pour dire que les
archosaures tous les archosaures était à
sang chaud
donc on est peut-être sur des animaux
qui étaient à sang chaud primitivement
et qu'ils sont redevenus un sang froid
précisément parce que ils sont trop gros
pour être à sang chaud s'il avait été à
son show il aurait littéralement quid
l'intérieur quoi donc ils sont revenus à
sang froid mais par contre il restait
aux mais au terme de toutes façons du
fait de leur gigantisme de la route de
l'art thaïlandaise et puis vous avez le
concept du coup de meo thermique ou là
vous avez tous les stades intermédiaires
possible entre ectothermes y en d'autres
termes il faut il qu'ils étaient remis
en mai au terme
vous avez tous les stades intermédiaires
possible et on appelle ça la maiso
termine donc dire que les dinosaures
étaient au mais au terme c'est un peu
comme c'est un peu ne prendre aucune
décision en réalité sur leur leur état
leur état métaboliques
c'est un peu la solution facile si vous
voulez pas prendre de risques vous dit
qu'ils étaient au maître mais au terme
est comme ça c'est c'est le sait les
lignes en fait la maison terminée c'est
tout le grill à que vous voyez entre les
quatre catégories tout ça c'est de la
maiso terme et donc est donc dans tout
ça dans tout sa balle en d'autres termes
il ya un truc qui est très important
dans le concept de dévolution de landau
thermiques chez les mammifères et c'est
que la taille ça compte
la taille est importante voilà
on dit souvent que la taille ne compte
pas mais si quand il s'agit de
thermomètres physiologie la taille est
importante quand on est un petit animal
on a beaucoup plus de mal à conserver sa
chaleur parce qu on a un tout petit
volume avec une grande surface
donc pour disperser la chaleur alors
qu'un gros animal et bien il a un gros
volume pour retenir la chaleur une toute
petite surface pour la disperser donc la
taille va être importante
et justement puisqu'on parle de tayeba
on sait que la transition entre terap
side et mammifères et alors là je vous
renvoie au cours de paléo mammalogie
j'ai peur que ce soit extrêmement
difficile de suivre le cours que je suis
en train de vous donner maintenant si
vous n'y connaissez rien en thérapie
donc je pense que un peu comme la
paléontologie du caroux secours va être
un va être un va avoir comme prérequis
d'avoir vu quand même au moins le cours
sur l'évolution des thérapies side donc
le cours de paléo mammalogie sur l'été
rapide mais bon si vous ne l'avez pas vu
on va on va en parler rapidement à la
fin du règne des thés rapide il y à une
transition cette transition elle se fait
des thérapies side aux mammifères et
cette transition des thérapies de
mammifères il ya beaucoup de choses qui
ont lieu à évolutive mans parlant entre
les terres apside les mammifères et mais
cette transition elle est aussi et
surtout marquée par une évolution de la
taille corporelle les terres apside
étaient en moyenne des animaux gros
voire moyen voire gros et la transition
vers les mammifères va s'opérer aussi
sur la taille du corps les mammifères
sont en général extrêmement petit donc
là vous voyez les thérapies 6
généralement ils flirtent dans la
cinquantaine à la centaine de kilos
minimum avec quelques terap si de
quelques terap site du trias comme tri
naxos dont qui devait flirter du côté
des de 1,6 kg donc vous avez toujours
une
un poids qui s'exprime en kg on va dire
celle été rapide et d'un seul coup au
milieu du trias vous là vous allez avoir
une transition tout l'été rap sites vont
devenir
tout petits ils vont devenir tout petit
avec des pois qui s'exprime en g
comme vous pouvez le voir ici donc je
jamais des poids qui vont excédé la
centaine de grammes ou très rarement
comme le castoro coda mais déjà là on
revient au mésozoïque et il va falloir
attendre le crétacé avec des trucs comme
rep et nos mamies sous à dallas terium
pour atteindre de nouveau des poids
exprimé en kg quoi donc vous avez tout
un passage à vide on va dire entre la
fin du trias enfin le milieu du trias et
la fin du jurassique où les mammifères
vont tous être vraiment très petit d'où
cette idée d'ailleurs que les mammifères
vivait à l'ombre des dinosaures cause
parce qu'ils étaient tout petits petits
et ça se voit très bien si on représente
la mâchoire en fait là donc là vous avez
la phylogénie des signaux dont tu donc
les signaux donc qui vont éventuellement
donner naissance aux mammifères donc les
mammifères ça commence ici avec mes gaz
austro dont voilà mes gazost road on est
bien morganucodon sont les premiers
mammifères et vous voyez ce sont des
tout petits animaux est déjà arrivé à
brazil terium donc la fin les tout
derniers disent hinault dont tu les tout
derniers synodaux pardon était déjà de
petite taille et vous voyez là comment
la transition s'est faite c'est même pas
une transition je veux dire à ce niveau
là c'est un casse il ya une cassure à un
moment de la phylogénie des signaux dont
tous les signaux deviennent tout petit
et pouf donne immédiatement naissance
aux mammifères qui sont tous tout petit
sauf certains représentants du crétacé
donc c'est cette transition
du coup on se dit qu'elle n'a été
possible que si les signaux dont était
déjà à sang chaud avant puisque pour
devenir tout petit et notamment
nocturnes parce qu'on pense que ces
premiers ce que ces premiers mammifères
étaient nocturne va pour être à la fois
pour pouvoir se permettre à la fois
d'être tout petit et nocturnes
on se dit que quand même être à sang
chaud ça semble être un pré requis alors
je sais qu'il existe des petits lézards
qui s'appelle les gecko qu'ils sont tout
petits nocturne et à sang froid
je veux dire tout le monde est au
courant 1
mais bon ça veut pas dire que les gecko
sont la règle
peut-être que les gecko ne sont qu'une
exception
en tout cas ça semble une hypothèse
raisonnable de se dire que les premiers
mammifères pour pouvoir se permettre
d'être à la fois petit et nocturnes
il fallait déjà qu'il soit à son show
donc la question maintenant c'est quand
est-ce que ça ça serait apparu donc déjà
on peut commencer par se poser la
question quand est ce que la nocturne
alité est apparu quand est ce que les
mammifères sont devenus nocturne parce
que si on a plus de soleil
bon on peut plus réchauffé au soleil
donc le métabolisme à sang chaud devient
un avantage devient une nécessité même
j'ai envie de dire donc on peut chercher
déjà à dater cette transition entre
nocturne alité entre dealers nalité donc
vivre le jour et nocturne alité c'est à
dire vivre la nuit
donc comment sait-on que nos ancêtres
les premiers mammifères les mammifères
du mésozoïque était nocturne bien tout
simplement on le sait parce que la
plupart des mammifères aujourd'hui son
sont pas d'alto niamey ils sont ils
n'arrivent pas à voir les couleurs donc
ils sont bi chromatique
ils ont des yeux by chromatique ils ne
voient ils n'ont que deux types de
récepteurs dans leurs yeux et donc c'est
ce qui est représentée ici voilà ils
n'ont que deux types de récepteurs et il
n'y a guère que les primates qui eux
sont tri chromatique c'est-à-dire qu'ils
reviennent à une condition plus
primitives et qui est finalement dérivés
mais qui reviennent à une condition où
on a une capacité de voir trois couleurs
différentes alors je ne dis pas trois
couleurs c'est celle des récepteurs donc
les récepteurs ils ont une sensibilité
qui s'exprime en courbe
donc il ya un pic qui correspond à une
couleur mais effectivement la courbe
permet de voir aussi d'autres
longueur d'onde donc d'autres couleurs
mais bref donc une vision qui est bi
chromatique primitivement chez les
mammifères est quasiment tous les
mammifères ont des leçons que bichromate
ils ne sont patrick romat comme le sont
les primates les primates sont une
exception dans ce cas là et à linverse
on sait que tous les autres tétrapodes
que ce soit les oiseaux les reptiles les
fallait les arts les pulls et comment
les poissons enfin tout ça ils ont au
moins quatre quatre types différents de
récepteurs dans leurs yeux au moins au
moins et après vous avez les invertébrés
où on peut en avoir jusque 15 différents
récepteurs un couleurs dans les yeux
donc les les vertébrés de ce point de
vue là c'est vraiment pas la joie un
niveau vision chromatique mais bref donc
on sait que primitivement les vertébrés
du coup il avait au moins quatre
récepteurs et on s'imagine du coup que
les synappci de primitif que sont les
pays qu aux orres devais avoir 4
récepteur est l'ancêtre en commun de
tous les mammifères modernes lui devais
n'avoir que deux récepteurs puisque les
mammifères modernes sont bichromate et
ensuite il ya un troisième un troisième
récepteur qui a ré évolué chez les
primates à partir d'une duplication d'un
gène en fait il ya le gène pour le pour
une pour un des récepteurs qui sait
dupliquer qui s'est mis à muter de son
côté pour redonner un troisième type de
récepteur donc en fait duplication du
récepteur puis le récepteur à butée pour
donner à nouveau récepteur
bref tout ça pour dire que c'est pour ça
que les primates sont les seuls
mammifères chez qui vous allez avoir de
la couleur bleue voilà parce que parce
que c'est à peu près les seuls
mammifères qui sont capables de faire la
différence
donc ça ça cette capacité à ne pas voir
les couleurs cette incapacité je vais
dire à voir et à voir les couleurs on
pense que c'est un trait qui est commun
à tous les mammifères hérité d'un
ancêtre en commun et qu'est-ce qui
aurait pu expliquer la raison qu'elle
pourrait être la raison pour laquelle ce
cet ancêtre en commun ne voyait plus les
couleurs bas parce qu'ils étaient
nocturne et que dans la nuit ça sert à
que dalle de voir les couleurs et vous
imaginez bien que si pendant toute la
fin du trias et tout le tout le
jurassique les mammifères était petit et
nocturnes
vous vous imaginez bien qu'il ya eu il
s'est passé un long moment avant que
retrouver une vision des couleurs
c'est à dire revivre au soleil à la
lumière du jour s'est passé un très long
moment pendant laquelle ben ça servait
absolument à rien d'avoir une vision
plus que be chromatique
quoi donc et ça ça s'appelle d'ailleurs
le nocturnal bottleneck sont donc le
goulet d'étranglement nocturne
donc voilà les mammifères sont passés
par un goulet d'étranglement par une
phase de leur évolution où tous les
mammifères étaient nocturne et du coup
les mammifères ont ré évoluer ensuite
sont redevenus des urnes
mais à partir d'un ancêtre en commun
nocturne ce qui fait que ben ils n'ont
ils nous ont une vue qui est uniquement
by chromatique et tout ça ça
s'accompagne de nouveaux caractères en
fait du qui évolue à la même époque
donc pour compenser justement la perte
delà de la vision pour compenser le fait
que la vision devient maintenant un
organe sensoriel assez secondaires
notamment dans un environnement nocturne
et bien les mammifères va les les sino
d'hondt qui ont éventuellement donner
naissance aux mammifères qu'on appelle
les pro b dounia tu es bien ces signaux
donc très dérivés vont compenser avec
d'autres organes des sens il va noter
c'est là notamment qu'on va voir le
développement des bulbes olfactifs donc
voici brasil y terium l'un des six lots
dont tu les plus proches des mammifères
les bulbes olfactifs vous voyez de
brazil terium sont absolument
gigantesque comparé à son petit cousin
sino dont tu m'as cet homme natus donc
les bulbes olfactifs le sens de l'odorat
va venir compenser la perte de la vue le
louis va aussi venir compenser la perte
de la vue c'est chez ces signaux dombes
dérivés qu on va commencer à voir une
petite papilles apparaître et 7 papilles
va se développer et commencer à
s'enrouler
pour former ce qui deviendra la cochlée
donc c'est là que la cochlée commence à
se former aussi donc
l'audition on va aussi venir compenser
la perte de la perte de la vue enfin le
du mois la réduction du sens de la vue
et c'est aussi par là on en reparlera un
peu plus tard qu'on va commencer à voir
l'évolution des moustaches donc on peut
suivre l'évolution du nerf trijumeau le
nerf qui innerve les moustaches et c'est
là qu'on va avoir les premiers indices
d'évolution des moustaches mais on en
reparlera un petit peu plus tard et tout
ça donc ces évolutions de du système
sensoriel donc le système sensoriel qui
perd du point de vue de la vue mais qui
gagne sur l'audition là le toucher et
sur le factions et bien tout ça ça ça va
de pair aussi avec des changements du
cerveau et notamment une augmentation de
la taille du cerveau qui a lieu
justement pendant le mésozoïque au début
du mésozoïque vous voyez pour le cerveau
d'un seul coup devient aux gigantesques
en tout cas déjà au mésozoïque vous avez
ici morganucodon ead rocco diom avec la
taille du cerveau l'a exprimé en
quotient dans ses valises à sion je vous
renvoie à notre cours sur l'évolution du
cerveau qui aura lieu dans quelques
semaines mais ici en gros le sérieux la
taille du cerveau moyens double puis
triple puis quintuple ici chez les mots
notres m
donc ça cette augmentation de la taille
du cerveau est certainement liées
justement à ces nouveaux caractères qui
apparaissent ces nouveaux ces nouveaux
organes des sens qui évolue chez les
sino dont tu es ces nouveaux organes des
sens qui évolue chez les signaux donc
qui de cours requiert plus de plus de
computing power quoi le plus de il ya
plus de il faut plus de ram pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir gérer toutes ces
informations
ça augmente la taille du cerveau ça
augmente la taille des hémisphères
cérébraux qui de même vont nécessiter
plus d'énergie et donc générer plus de
chaleur et ça donc ça va aussi de pair
avec l'évolution de bordeaux termine un
plus gros cerveau ça génère plus de
chaleur le cerveau ça c'est un organe
qui est très
au mans en énergie c'est un organe qui
est très énergivore et du coup qui
produit beaucoup de chaleur parce que
ben ils brûlent l'énergie brûle les
calories pour faire pour générer de
l'intelligence et pour en tout cas
générer de la la coordination et cette
énergie brûlé littéralement se dégage
sous forme de chaleur et cette chaleur
faut bien qu'elle ait quelque part elle
part dans le sang et donc le sens de via
chaud voilà donc ça le cerveau c'est
aussi une étape importante en fait donc
pour avoir un gros cerveau il faut avoir
le sang chaud mais plus on a un gros
cerveau plus on a le sang chaud aussi
donc c'est on sait pas exactement dans
quel ordre ça a évolué mais en tout cas
c'est c'est une synergie
c'est très clairement une synergie puis
après on a des voix dissonantes
évidemment je ne peux pas ne pas vous
présenter les voix dissonantes notamment
des études de l'oeil
ce qu'on appelle la noce claireaux tic
chez les ch et l'épée dicos d'or qui ont
montré que déjà les premiers pélico
szohr comme dit métro dont était
probablement nocturne
donc ce qui remettrait en question le
scénario du du goulet d'étranglement
dokht urnes du mésozoïque puisque les
pays causant ont vécu bien avant le
mésozoïque on parle de la fin du
paléozoïque là c'est ça voudrait dire
que déjà à l'époque il y avait de la
nocturne a dit et avant même le goulet
d'étranglement nocturne et puis on a les
mots notres aime les mots notres m qui
ont qui ont eu trois récepteurs en fait
ils n'ont pas que deux récepteurs les
mots notres m par contre c'est pas les
mêmes récepteurs qu'on retrouve chez les
marsupiaux et les laits placentaire donc
c'est intéressant aussi c'est plutôt
intéressant aussi les mots notres aimons
trois récepteurs mais qui sont pas les
mêmes en fait que chez dès que chez les
autres mammifères et du coup ça c'est
pareil ça ça fout un peu la merde dans
le scénario qu'on s'imagine être
l'évolution du nocturne al bottleneck du
goulet d'étranglement
mais bon ce sont des petites épines dans
le pied qui ne remettent pas en question
l'idée générale que pendant le
mésozoïque les mammifères étaient
fortement fortement fortement nocturne à
part peut-être les mots notres m du coup
on ne sait pas
mais voilà il faut que je vous présente
du coup à chaque fois le pour et le
contre
puisque s'il n'y avait que ça bah là on
serait s'il n'y avait en fait que les
preuves que je vais vous présenter la
ses preuves la ses preuves la ses
preuves là tout ça ben ce serait très
facile de dire ah bah le sang chaud il a
forcément évolué là vous avez l'arbre
phylogénétique bas le sang chaud il a
évolué quand il ya un gros cerveau pouf
ici où on avait déjà tout l'arsenal des
mammifères à sang chaud ben oui mais non
c'est pas si simple que ça ce n'est pas
si simple
alors quelles sont les preuves
du coup là que je viens de vous
présenter quelques quelques éléments de
discussion mais on a loin on est loin
d'avoir fait tout le tour des preuves
alors quelles sont les preuves
alors avant de parler de quelles sont
les preuves de l'évolution de landau
terminé on va déjà parlé de qu'elles ne
sont pas les preuves de landau terme il
ya notamment une preuve d'un landau
thermique y ait beaucoup invoqué dans la
littérature et même sur internet si vous
renseigner c'est l'évolution de ce qu'on
appelle les cornées naseaux ou des
turbines au alors les turbines au ce
sont des espèces de deux bateaux deux
turbines des eaux en forme de spirale
que vous avez dans le nez et qui
permettre à l'air d'être réchauffé quand
vous inspirer et refroidi quand vous
expirez donc réchauffer l'air que vous
inspirez chauffer et refroidir l'air que
vous expirez ça n'a d'intérêt que si
vous essayez de de massana l'intérêt que
si vous essayez de conserver votre
chaleur déjà quand vous expirez vous
essayer de conserver votre chaleur grâce
aux turbines au mais surtout réchauffer
l'air quand vous inspirer ça n'a
d'intérêt que si vous êtes vous même à
son show donc c'est un c'est un signe
que vous êtes à sang chaud d'avoir des
turbines au du coup et on sait que les
reptiles par exemple n'ont pas de
turbine au les oiseaux ont des turbines
au les mammifères ont des turbines au
les reptiles crocodile inclus non non
pas du mois du mois ils n'en ont pas d
très développé les crocodiles ont des
petites turbines au quand même mais bon
bref ils sont pas très développée mais
déjà il faut relativiser ce cas ça de
deux façons différentes la première déjà
c'est que tous les autres turbines au ne
savent pas à réchauffer l'air ou à le
refroidir quand il ressort
les turbines au les turbines au sont
principalement là pour soutenir de la
muqueuse olfactive est donc le rôle
principal de la plupart des turbines au
dans votre nez c'est en réalité de
capter les molécules odorantes
[Applaudissements]
donc c'est pas de réchauffer ou de
refroidir l'air c'est réellement
réellement leur rôle c'est de capter les
molécules odorantes
donc il ya qu'une toute petite partie
des turbines au qu'on appelle les
turbines au maxillaire donc les turbines
au qui sont plus en avant dans votre nez
cela par contre ils n'ont pas de
muqueuse olfactive donc leur rôle est
uniquement de réchauffer de refroidir
l'air inspirez et expirez donc déjà il
faut relativiser ça c'est que trouver
des preuves de turbines au dans l'absolu
c'est pas forcément de trouver des
preuves de turbines dans le registre
fossile dans l'absolu c'est pas
forcément une preuve de dando termine si
les turbines au en question sont des
turbines au situé à l'arrière de la
cavité olfactives
c'est probablement plus des turbines au
des turbines au à fonctions à fonction
olfactives
donc il faut trouver si vous trouve si
vous voulez dire que votre animal
fossiles dans lequel vous avez trouvé 1
turbine à la l'intérieur était un animal
à sang chaud
ben il faut que ce turbine allant
question soit si tu es vraiment à
l'avant de la cavité nasale
voilà pour qu'on soit vraiment
complètement sûr qu'il ne s'agissait pas
d'un turbine adolphe actifs et la
deuxième essai là j'en viens à la
deuxième raison pour laquelle les
turbines au ne sont pas des bonnes
preuves d'évolution de landau thermie
c'est que de toute façon les turbines au
le registre fossile des turbines au
celle été rapide
il est égal à zéro voilà c'est que de
toute façon vous n'avez même pas vous
poser la question puisque on n'a jamais
trouvé de turbinage fossilisés chez un
thérapie d' absolument jamais alors vous
allez voir des articles et des choses
qui vous disent que oui mais alors cette
espèce là elle a des espèces de crète à
l'intérieur des narines qui était
peut-être attachés à des turbines au qui
était cartilagineux voyez alors le
turbine hall cartilagineuse c'est la
solution du pauvre
on est bien d'accord que c'est déjà
c'est déjà suffisamment une hypothèse en
soin de dire que turbine à l'égal en
d'autres termes il faut déjà voir que
déjà ce lien là il est hypothétique
alors si en plus le turbine hall en
question on le voit pas parce qu'ils
étaient cartilagineuse ça fait vraiment
l'hypothèse du pauvre donc donc non on
va tout de suite évacué les turbines au
la présence d'eau sur bino à l'intérieur
de corner naseaux c'est d'une c'est pas
une bonne indication parce que la
plupart des corps des naseaux n'ont rien
à voir avec le landau terminait 2 2
de toute façon celle été rapide on en a
pas et je crois que même chez les
mammifères mésozoïque il ya que les ja
que chez certaines espèces du crétacé
qu'on a trouvé des turbines des vrais
turbines au jeudi
il ya que des mammifères du crétacé chez
qui on a trouvé les turbines au pour
l'instant on n'a toujours pas au
mésozoïque ni eau ni au trias enfin on
n'a toujours pas au jurassique ni au
trias non bref donc et puis trouver des
turbines au chez une espèce de mammifère
c'est pas c'est pas exceptionnel c'est
normal c'est des mammifères donc ça nous
avance à rien bref donc quelles sont les
preuves et bien l'épreuve déjà la
première preuve qui a été avancé
historiquement par bart baker c'est la
posture donc la posture chez les
mammifères qui n'est pas rampante mais
dressée sur les pattes
cette posture chez les mammifères en
fait l aide au dynamisme de la
respiration
donc il faut savoir que chez les
reptiles dont chez les lézards notamment
quand les lézards sprint les lézards
sont capables de courir aussi vite voire
plus vite que les mammifères de même
taille
c'est pas un problème d'aller vite ou
pas mais quand un lézard sprint il est
obligé de retenir sa respiration parce
que du fait qu'il a les bras du côté du
corps et les jambes du côté du corps en
fait il est obligé de faire ça à chaque
fois qu'il marche pour aller chercher
devant lui comme ça parce que c'est un
lézard rampant et que du coup il faut
qu'ils fassent des mouvements de côté et
ça ça qu'on pressent les poumons d'un
côté de l'autre d'un côté de l'autre ce
qui fait que le lézard ne peux pas
respirer
pendant qu'ils courent du coup les
lézards cours en apnée ça ça a été
observée je veux dire ça a été observée
chez les lézards les lézards cours en
apnée du coup ils ne peuvent pas courir
longtemps
al'inverse les mammifères qui ont une
posture parra sagittale avec les bras
droit les bras et les jambes droit sous
le corps comme les dinosaures d'ailleurs
ont donc cette position sur parra
sagittale et quand il courait bien leur
leurs deux poumons ce qu'on presse
d'avant en arrière quand vous regardez
un chien ou un cheval courir en fait les
mammifères quadrupèdes quand ils courent
leurs poumons ceux des compresses et se
compressent en rythme avec le avec leurs
rythmes de galop et du coup ça c'est ça
ça permet du coup de respirer en même
temps qu'ils courent donc les animaux
qui sont et ça ça va de pair du coup
avec un métabolisme qu'on pense être
élevé ça augmente l'endurance et
l'endurance c'est quelque chose qu'on
retrouve chez les animaux à sang chaud
pas chez les animaux à sang froid et ça
permet de soutenir une course pendant
très longtemps et cette ce métabolisme
élevé maintenu c'est un symptôme d'un
métabolisme s'en fout voilà et du coup
ce que bakker a dit c'est que si on
regarde l'évolution des synapses id
l'évolution des synapses fidèle et très
simple plus divisée en trois en trois
grandes parties
basé sur la posture vous avez d'abord
les pays causeur qui avait une posture
rampante qui ressemblaient à des lézards
et qu'il y avait une posture rampante
qui était donc probablement à sang froid
vous avez les thérapies qui avait une
posture semi érigé donc transitionnelle
et puis vous avez les sino donc
notamment les plus dérivés comme les
treaty l'eau donc qui avait une posture
complètement érigé qui donc devait être
à sang chaud mais bon encore une fois ce
genre d'arguments sur la posture
enfin je pense que vous en avez déjà
repéré les faiblesses c'est c'est à dire
que c'est c'est plus à symptômes qu'une
qu'une cause c'est à dire que
on peut tout à fait être par assagi
talent et à sang froid je vois pas ce
qui empêcherait un animal d'être
imposture érigé et à sang froid
en fait c'est pour ça que je dis c'est
juste un symptôme plus qu'une réelle une
réelle une réelle corrélation donc bref
y'a pas davantage si vous voulez il n'y
a pas davantage à être on n'imagine pas
effectivement à l'animal à sang chaud
être rampant parce que du coup il peut
pas respirer en même temps qu'ils
courent par contre on peut tout à fait
imaginer l animal à sang froid avec des
membres dressées sous le corps ça pose
pas vraiment problème et après vous avez
les crocodiles qui sont rampants quand
il marche mais qui sont érigés quand il
court et ça c'était aussi le cas de
certains thérapie de certains terap
sites comme le gorgol obtient que vous
voyez en eau
il avait ce qu'on appelle la dual gates
posture où ils étaient rampants enfin
semi rampant quand il était au repos
mais par contre dès qu'ils se mettaient
à courir il pouvait passer en posture
érigé et galoper donc c'est donc voilà
c'est un corps et la cc il ya une
corrélation certes mais elle est assez
faible
voilà c'est juste ça donc il nous faut
plus de preuves alors on est allé
chercher du côté de la géochimie c'est à
dire qu'on regarde la chimie des eaux et
cette chimie des eaux et notamment celle
de l'oxygène donc les la chimie du fâ la
chimie du fond du phosphore et l'oxygène
enfin dans la chimie de l'eau en général
vous dire de manière générale elle
dépend de la façon dont vous acquérez
les éléments de votre de votre milieu
donc le carbone va dépendre de la façon
dont vous vous nourrissez et l'oxygène
notamment va dépendre de la façon dont
vous respirez et de la façon dont votre
organisme va ensuite géré cet oxygène
dans la combustion justement de
l'énergie de votre énergie physiologique
l'énergie physiologique qui passe donc
par l'oxydation de des molécules
d'énergie de l'atp donc cette saisie au
top de l'oxygène on pense qu'ils vont
avoir qui vont varier la chine la
composition chimique de vaud
on pense que la composition chimique des
eaux fossiles va varier en fonction de
si le fossile appartenait à l'animal en
de termes ou un animal ectothermes voilà
et donc ça ça a été fait celle été
rapide par un de mes collègues qui
s'appelle kevin wray avec qui on avait
fait une vidéo auparavant et on avait
déjà parlé tout ça est donc cette chimie
osseuse apparemment elle a l'air de
révéler que c'est pas tellement chez des
signaux dont en particulier que la queue
que la chimie de l'oxygène c'est miss et
mister changé mais apparemment c'est
plus un problème dû à l'extinction
permien trias à savoir que les espèces
enfin les grandes familles qui existait
avant la limite permise trias et est
apparemment avait une chimie de
l'oxygène qui ressemble plus à des
espèces à sang froid et après la limite
permise trias on a apparemment une
chimie de l'oxygène qui indique plus un
métabolisme à sang chaud et donc l es
deux grands survivants de la limite
permise trias je le rappelle ce sont les
signaux l'ontt et les lady sino dont tu
donc les listes rose or par exemple
et puis du côté des synodaux que vous
avez le trac second et ses dons qu'il a
fait il a échantillonné ce qu'a fait
kevin wray il a échantillonné du coup
avant et après la limite permise trias
et il a découvert que l'on qu'il y avait
converse évolution convergente d'une
géochimie de l'oxygène qui semble a
indiqué une ans doté remis après la
limite permise trias chez les disciples
dont tu es chez les synodes ont donc
c'est ce que vous voyez ici en noir vous
avez espèces ectothermes en rouge espèce
en de termes ou reconstitués ectothermes
est reconstituée en de termes
ici vous avez la limite permise atria si
vous voyez que chez dc nous donne comme
chez les sino donc on passe au rouge
après la limite permise trias alors il
manque quand même les terros efa lien ce
serait bien de pouvoir vérifier ça sur
des terreaux sefa liens du trias
justement voir s'ils ont eux aussi été
affecté par ça et après il y a il ya
quand même le fait qu'il ya un
changement
ben justement on passe du permien au
trias donc les environnements du permis
a et ceux du trias sont
différents l'un de l'autre donc il ya
aussi ce changement chimique de
l'environnement qu'il faut prendre en
compte
ils ont quand même essayé de quoi ils
ont essayé enfin kevin a essayé de
corriger ici le cet effet de
l'environnement mais ça paraît quand
même bizarre que d'un seul coup entre le
permis altria s'il ya un changement de
la chimie des eaux et que ce changement
de la chimie des eaux serait pas non
plus corrélés du tout un changement de
la chimie générale de l'environnement
voilà mais en tout cas c'est un c'est un
truc intéressant et c'est d'autant plus
intéressant que quand on regarde la
paléo histologie il ya quelque chose qui
a l'air de se passer aussi de ce côté là
du côté de la paléo histologie on
constate aussi que les synodes honte du
trias ont des cernes de croissance qui
est qu'ils sont beaucoup moins marqué
que ceux du permis et on allait on a
notamment envoyé ici alors là c'est un
peu plus distribuer phylogénétiquement
mais en gros les dc no doubt vous voyez
ils ont des cernes de croissance bien
distribués tout au long de leur zoo donc
ça veut dire que il avait vraiment une
interruption de croissance chaque hiver
donc s'il ya interruption de croissance
il y à sang froid
enfin il ya hectos tilly a pris kg
termine ensuite vous avez les terros et
fall ici vous avez peu d'interruption de
croissance mais elles sont toujours là
donc il ya toujours peau et qu'il était
remis ensuite vous avez les signes
montrent où là vous avez quelques cernes
de croissance vraiment sur la fin de
lost sur la bordure extérieure de l'os
mais tout le reste de l'os est
relativement homogène ce qui veut dire
plutôt endothermique ce qui veut dire
quelque chose de plus
en d'autres termes chez les 6 90 mais
apparemment là aussi on aurait
convergence entre lesdits sino dont elle
est si nos dons dont trias donc a priori
on aurait un bon signal indiquant une
évolution convergente de landau terme
icher les signaux dont l ai dit si nos
dons au trias soutenu par l'apa les
autres par la paléo histologie et la
géochimie avec quand même les petites
remarques que j'ai fait sur la géochimie
et avec les petites remarques sur la
paléo histologie qui est que
l'histologie ne vous indique que lomé au
thermique
ça ne vous indique pas landau termine
c'est à dire que s'il ya un changement
climatique qui a lieu au trias et qui
fait que le trias est plus chaud ce qui
est le cas eh bien on va avoir
on va avoir l'impression d'une
endothermique alors qu'en fait tout ce
qu'on verra ses de lomé au termiste à
dire que en général c'était plus chaud
donc les cernes de croissance sont moins
marquées donc ça il faut il faut pas
l'oublier non plus dans l'interprétation
de ces données là et puis le problème
c'est que ces données là elles sont pas
forcément cohérente avec d'autres
données qu'on a par ailleurs donc là on
regarde par exemple la taille des
cellules des cellules sanguines donc la
taille des globules rouges
on est capable de reconstituer la taille
maximale des globules rouges en
regardant l'histologie osseuse parce
qu'on voit les canaux donc ce qu'on
appelle les canaux à vers sien on voit
les canaux qui était empruntée par des
des des vaisseaux sanguins à l'intérieur
de l'os et donc les vaisseaux sanguins
leur taille leur taille est indicative
de la taille maximale des cellules qui
sont capables d'aller dedans et
notamment les globules rouges
et donc quand on regarde l'évolution de
la taille des globules rouges tel que
reconstitué à partir justement de la
taille de ses dimensions du calibre de
ces vaisseaux sanguins et bien on
constate qu'il y à une transition vers
une taille de de globules de globules
rouges plus mammalienne déjà enfin que
l'on constate que cette évolution elle
est pas si tranchée que ça il n'y a pas
il ya effectivement quelque chose qui se
passe ici aux alentours de la limite
permise trias mais avec quand même la
possibilité que se soit produit avant la
limite permise trias et avec la taille
de globules rouges mammalienne
définitivement atteinte uniquement chez
les mammifères
donc là on a une une image on va dire un
peu plus graduelle de cette évolution
vous voyez que là on est
on n'a pas vraiment de coupure nette à
la limite permise atria sont à un
changement qui est beaucoup plus
graduelle au cours de l'évolution de
décines abside et si on regarde
après les interprétations qui ont été
faites de ceux des signaux issus de la
paléo histologie donc je vous ai dit on
à une transition donc depuis des
histologie de pau et kg terme vers des
histologie domeo terme entre la limite
permise trias entre l'aele à la limite
entre le permien pardon et le trias donc
là la grande crise d'extinction permien
trias sic
donc on la voit effectivement chez lady
sino dont tu es chez les signaux dont tu
es aussi chez les hétéros céphale
d'ailleurs là les terros et fall ont été
étudiées pour ça et cette transition en
fait aller elle est tellement
parfaitement corrélé avec la limite
permise trias que l a été plutôt
interprété comme un non pas comme un
changements métaboliques mais comme un
char un changement dans la vitesse de
croissance c'est à dire que vous le
savez depuis que je vous ai parlé de la
crise permien trias cependant la bio
strati le cours de biostratigraphie du
carreau il y à un phénomène qui
s'appelle l'effet lilliput et cet effet
les dix buts
il permet aux espèces d'atteindre la
maturité sexuelle plus vite et un autre
bon moyen d'atteindre la maturité
sexuelle plus vite c'est aussi de
grandir plus vite et quand on grandit
plus vite et bien on a moins de deux
zones d'arrêt de croissance que pendant
que quand on grandit lentement et du
coup moins john-david croissance ça
ressemble furieusement à de l'osce qui a
grandi de façon permanente
comme chez les hommes et au terme donc
peut-être qu'en fait ce changement dans
la paléo histologie qui semble avoir
lieu à la limite permise trias ne
seraient peut-être que le reflet d'une
adaptation aux conditions de la limite
permise trias qui ont imposé de grandir
plus vite et pas forcément de et pas
forcément de devenir à sang chaud
et comme je le dis il ya d'autres
indices paléo histologique qui ne
suivent pas parfaitement cette coupure
qu'il y aurait eu entre le permien trias
donc c'est une question que ça reste en
suspens voilà et ce sont des indices qui
sont extrêmement intéressants
en tout cas si ça si on peut vraiment
corps et laissa à lomé au termine pas si
on peut vraiment parler domeo terminée
qu'on peut vraiment la ram l'accord et
léa de l'an ii termine alors on aurait
effectivement un signal cohérent de
convergence évolutive entre les 10 6 91
des synodes honte vers un métabolisme à
sang chaud mais évidemment comme je
voulais faire remarquer en début de
cours le lundi ce majeur qui permettrait
de dire si oui ou non on est face à des
espèces qui étaient aux moeurs en de
termes ou pas bah ce serait de découvrir
des poils de la même façon que chez les
dinosaures on a cette évolution très
très bien documenté des filaments de
plumes chez les théropodes ce serait
bien de découvrir le même genre de
séries évolutive
les thérapies side qui nous montrerait
qu'il avait des poils et que donc il
avait cette isolation du corps permise
par les poils qui serait directement la
preuve de l'ordre de termites du sang
chaud chez ces animaux là le problème
c'est que voici la totalité du registre
fossile du poil devant vos yeux ébahis
et voilà ça dans mes aisselles et je ne
déconne pas c'est vraiment la totalité
du registre fossile sur cette diapos
donc les premiers poils sont documentés
chez des mammifères du mésozoïque donc
ce sont déjà des mammifères donc via
sanaa ça ne nous apporte absolument rien
voilà donc on allait les arrahma idées
et les doc odt anti dec
donc on a donc on a un à rama idées que
vous voyez ici je crois que ces
volatiles terium je ne sais plus où je
sais plus exactement le nom de celui là
mais c'est un art à mal l'idée qu'il y
avait une espèce de deux membranes
mais je crois pas que ces volatiles côté
rieur volatiles comme terium c'est pas
un art amaya idée mais bref vous avez un
mammifère amara maya idées avec des
poils qui nous vient de chine
vous avez castoro coda qui est un doc
odt honte qui nous vient aussi de chine
et qui a aussi des poils préserver et
vous avez à peu près la totalité du
registre fossile du poil au mésozoïque
voilà il ya aussi ce pinot l'estey ce
qui vient de d'espagne qui a aussi pris
sur lequel il ya des poils préserver
aussi
donc voilà la totalité du registre du
poil et avant ça qu'est-ce qu'on abat on
n'a pas grand chose à se mettre sous la
dent donc on a quelques mots me qui
viennent du caroux mais le problème
c'est que ces momies en tout cas elles
ont pas d'une de ce qu'elles sont pas
encore été étudiée d'une et de deux donc
il faudrait étudier
l'histologie de ce qu'on croit être de
là pour regarder si ça c'est de la peau
c'est quand même magnifique à veiller
sur ceux sur ce lit strory cela vous
avez les quatre pattes ici du bistrot
russe la colonne vertébrale qui serait
ici et là vous avez la tête
donc là si ce qu'on voit là c'est
effectivement de la peau et pas juste un
ovule bizarroïdes
mais il faudrait pouvoir faire des
coupes histologiques pour en être sûr et
sain pas encore été fait mais si c'est
vraiment de la peau c'est
c'est une très très belle momie
fossilisés quoi et donc c'est ça
indiquerait du cou qui avait pas de
poils mais le problème c'est que les
poêles ça peut se perdre pendant là
pendant la taphonomie pendant le
l'enterrement du fossile donc l'absence
de poils sur cette momie de liste rose
aux russes quand bien même elle serait
réel bah ça veut pas dire pour autant
que l'animal vivant n'avait pas de poils
et là on a aussi c'est ce fragment de
peau d'un possible et ce thème et nos su
ce qui est un dino céphale de russie et
qui étouffe globuleux alors ça vient de
la face du lait se termine au sujet du
museau de lester mais nos succès ce
serait tout globuleux il ya eu des
études histologique qui ont été faites
dessus qui qui suggère pas grand chose à
part que ça pourrait être des glandes
mais on sait pas trop en tout cas si on
en croit le registre fossile tel qu'on
le connaît aujourd'hui apparemment les
thérapies side avait la peau nue pas de
poils bon point d'interrogation et on a
et on a ce pays qu aux orres enfin on a
pas mal de pays cause hors du début du
permien chez qui on a retrouvé des
écailles donc là c'est le plus beau
d'entre eux qui vient d'allemagne et
vous voyez ici la présence des cayes ne
fait absolument aucun doute
on a aussi des empreintes du ventre de
pélico szohr qui ont été préservées dans
du sédiment qui montre aussi qu'ils
avaient des grands des cayes exactement
comme les crocodiles sur le ventre au
moins donc on a on à ses empreintes de
dca et donc chez les pays causeur et on
a aussi deux le tout premier le plus
ancien pélico szohr archéo thirith qui
est aussi préservé avec des traces des
cayes donc apparemment les pélico szohr
avait des écailles reptilienne ou
reptile qui ressemblait à celle des
reptiles l'été rapide pour autant qu'on
sache n'avait pas de poils point
d'interrogation
et puis il ya les mammifères qui ont des
poils et voilà la totalité de l'histoire
et le problème c'est qu'encore une fois
l'été rapide avec ou sans poils
les momies aurait pu perdre leurs poils
avant d'être fossilisés quoi donc c'est
ça le truc
c'est ça le truc et puis on a ces
déjections qui ont été retrouvés dans le
permien et qui ont des structures
filamenteuses bizarre voilà donc on a
des coprolithe qui contiennent des
structures filamenteuses les comprend
les coprolithe sont elles-mêmes
attribués à des thérapies site ça veut
pas dire que les poêles à l'intérieur
appartiennent a été rapide
je vous rappelle que c'est coprolithe
date de la fin du permien et qu'à la fin
du permien qu'est-ce qu'on a qui
apparaît les archosaures au nord et les
arcs aux héros morts
ils ont peut-être des filaments oui donc
donc quand bien même ces structures
filamenteuses à l'intérieur des
coprolithe ne serait pas juste des vers
parasites
1 parce que c'est possible aussi que ces
structures filamenteuses soit juste des
vers parasites
donc quand bien même ces structures
filamenteuses ne sauvait pas des vers
parasites mais bien des des structures
de kératine
et bah ça voudrait pas forcément dire
que les structures de kératine en
question appartiennent à des thérapies
de ça pourrait aussi appartenir à des
archosaures enfin des archosaures au mof
et du cou du coup ça laisse le doute ne
sais pas parce que la coprolithe
appartiendrait à un thé rapide que ce
qu'il a mangé c'est forcément du terap
sida donc il a forcément lécher ses
poils avant de les avoir mangé donc
donc voila vous vous êtes à peu près
autant coincé maintenant vous comprenez
pourquoi pourquoi je suis obligé de
faire un cours de deux heures sur
endothermique ou pas alors que la
réponse peut se donner en dix minutes
pour les dinosaures
[Rires]
maintenant il faut chercher du coût des
preuves indirectes de la présence de
poils vu que les prêts les preuves
directes de présence de poils sont très
très très sains conclusive et pour sabah
moi et mes collègues on a regardé ce
qu'on appelle le foramen pinéale le fera
mine pinéale qui est qui accueille un
oeil qui s'appelle l'oeil pinéale donc
déjà le final c'est intéressant pour la
question de landau thermie parce que
l'oeil pinéale des lui-même présent que
chez les ectothermes puisqu'il permet
entre autres fonctions une fonction de
une fonction de décisions sur est-ce que
je vais aller me carrés au soleil ou pas
voilà ce que lépine et al
il ne voit rien d'autre qu'à la
différence entre le jour et la nuit donc
en fait ils envoient des signaux au
cerveau là à travers le nerf pinéale que
vous voyez là donc il va s'illuminer
maintenant voilà on voit bien là le nerf
pinéale et senard pinéale donc ils
envoient des signaux cerveau à la glande
pinéale il dit à la glande pinéale à la
c'est là il fait jour la fois aller se
mettre au soleil la fois aller se
réchauffer et puis à la c la nuit va te
planquer va te planquer les en d'autres
termes non pas ça du coup les en
d'autres termes on passa donc l'oeil
pénal il est déjà intéressant pour ça et
donc est ce qu'il ya d'intéressant c'est
qu'il ya aussi un corps et là une
corrélation sur le crâne qui est très
très évidente qui s'appelle le foramen
pinéale donc où se trouve l oeil pinéale
et il se trouve que nos amis tes rapide
ils ont des gros foramen pinéale des
gros foramen pinet haut du cou des ils
ont un gros faux ramène pinéale donc on
peut suivre l'évolution de cette hype
idéal à travers l'évolution
il ya aussi que le foramen pinéale il
est aussi plus ou moins corrélée à la
présence de poils et on le sait grâce à
des mutations qui avaient été faites sur
des souris les souris qui ont une
mutation d'un gène qui s'appelle msx2
non plus de poils n'ont plus de glandes
mammaires et ont un foramen pinéale donc
elle ressemble un terreau abside en fait
à l'idée qu'on se fait d'un reptile
malien au final elles n'ont pas de poils
pas de glandes mammaires et un trou dans
le crâne comme les reptiles maliens
comme on s'imagine que les attinois
malia l'avait
alors que les souris de type sauvage
donc qu'ils n'ont pas le gène msx2 muté
ces souris l'aele ils ont des poils des
glandes mammaires et elles n'ont pas de
format même pinera donc est-ce que la
condition mammalienne ne serait elle pas
due à une mutation qui a eu lieu à un
moment du gène msx2 donc le gène msx2
qui était autrefois dans la condition
des souris qu'on considère mutante
aujourd'hui mais qui a muté chez les
thérapies site pour devenir le msx2
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui chez les
mammifères
et ça c'est plutôt intéressant c'est
plutôt intéressant comme comme mutation
et donc si on arrivait à suivre du coup
le l'évolution du foramen pinéale à
travers les temps géologiques et bien on
pourrait dire voilà ceux qui ont un
foramen pinéale avait le gène msx2 en
version ancienne et ceux qui ont pas de
faux ramène pinéale sont ceux qui ont le
gène msx2 en version 2.0
donc voilà clairement vous auriez la
condition mutants msx2 pour les
thérapies des la condition non mutants
msx2 pour les mammifères et quand on
suit l'évolution du foramen pinéale à
travers l'évolution des mammifères
on se rend compte que les gorgones
obtient les dix hinault donc et les
terros et fabien ont tous ou presque
un foramen pinéale et même les premiers
disent innocente les dissidents dos du
père bien mais quand on arrive au dc 90
du trias et notamment une famille une
famille qui s'appelle lessines obinna
clébard dans les pro b nomia donc les
ancêtres des mammifères les ancêtres
directs des mammifères parmi les signaux
dont tu es bien là le foramen pinéale
d'un seul coup pouf il disparaît avec
avec une petite zone de variabilité
entre les terreaux céphalées les signaux
dont tu donc les terreaux ses fans
notamment il ya beaucoup de variabilité
au niveau de la présence du forum in
pinéale donc peut-être une évolution
convergente aussi de la condition de dms
x2 chez les terreaux ces femmes et on a
un autre groupe qui s'appelle les
signaux gogniat tchéquie aussi le
foramen pinéale va devenir convergents
mais que je n'ai pas représentés chez
qui le foramen finale va devenir
variable par
mais que j'ai pas représentés ici faute
de place mais on a une petite zone de
variabilité au début du trias en gros et
ensuite chez les pro b naudinat milieu
trias bam le foramen disparaît sec et ne
réapparaît plus jamais et ça c'est la
branche qui va donner naissance aux
mammifères
donc c'est quand même pas une
coïncidence enfin ça fait quand même
bizarre comme pour une coïncidence
voyez que le foramen pinéale
disparaissent sec chez les pros beknown
yat alors que chez les autres c'est
variable ou présent tout le temps et
donc ça ça pourrait être le signe qu'il
y à une mutation de msx de chez ces
mammifères pro b naudinat ceux là même
qui justement sont devenus petit
rappelez vous ces mammifères pro b
nominal qui eux mêmes sont devenus tout
petit donc ont perdu leur troisième et y
ont vu msx2 devenir plus d'un mal like
plus qui a atteint sa mutation qu'on
voit aujourd'hui chez les mammifères
modernes et qui de fait nous indiquerait
non seulement la perte du foramen
pinéale mais aussi du coup l'apparition
de la fourrure et l'apparition des
glandes mahb en fin de déclin de la mer
donc on aurait presque on serait presque
la face au gène le gène de la de la
mamie ferry tude et on peut marquer sa
de l'origine des synodes honte entre 241
et 246 millions d'années ici j'ai avec
les 246 millions d'années mais la dette
a été révisé entre deux donc c'est entre
241 et 246 millions d'années que ce que
ce gène aurait évolué et donc ça ce
serait un signe du coup que les poêles
seraient apparus chez les pros benatia
ou du moins se serait stabilisée chez
les pros benmouna tiens puisque comme je
les dis il ya une petite zone de
variabilité avant donc il y aurait des
zones de mutations ponctuelles mais ça
se serait stabilisé franchement chez les
pros benatia entre 241 et 246 millions
d'années et donc ça ça correspond comme
je les dis à la réduction de taille des
synodes honte et ça correspond aussi à
au début du du goulet d'étranglement
nocturne
si l'on se pose la question d'où
viennent les poils
c'est une question qui est intéressante
à se poser dans le cadre de l'évolution
de l'or de termites d'où viennent les
poils et bien on rencontre dans la
littérature un gène en particulier qui
s'appelle le gène ed a et ce gène
ed a c'est un gène qui contrôle les
phanères donc les reptiles qui ont une
mutation du gène ed a que vous voyez sur
la gauche là celui celui qui est tout en
haut il a une mutation du gène o'dea qui
fait qu'il n'a pas des cayes comme vous
pouvez voir donc il à la police
peut-être comme nos listes rose aux
russes dont on parlait tout à l'heure et
les mutants les mutants mammifères ed à
eybens eux ils n'ont pas de poils c'est
ce que vous voyez c'est cet acteur la
queue qui est très connu
je me rappelle plus son nom mais c'est
un acteur très connu pour ses seconds
rôles il a qui jouent souvent des
personnages effrayants des parce que
justement il à cette mutation du gène
edf qui fait qu'il n'a pas de sourcils
et donc et qui les choses du coup il est
aussi chauffe
je crois qu'il n'a pas d'ongles non plus
sur les doigts mais en tout cas c'est
surtout le fait qu'il ait pas de
sourcils de fait qu'il ait pas de
sourcils ça rend son regard extrêmement
profond extrêmement méchant pour nous
humains et du coup ça du coup ça le fait
beaucoup de seconds rôles notamment en
méchant à cause de ça c'est un acteur
très connu et c'est très connu qui l'a
justement cette maladie génétique rare
issu de la mutation du gène ed a donc
donc ce même gène en fait fait des
lézards sans écailles et des mammifères
sans poil ce qui montre bien que les
écailles comme les poils ont la même
origine embryologie qu est cet embryon
cette origine en brio logique c'est ce
qu'on appelle les plats code
donc il ya eu une à une époque où on
pensait que les poils étaient apparues
entre les écailles donc on pensait qu'il
y avait eu des écailles puis que les
poils étaient poussés entre les écailles
puis que les écailles avait disparu ce
qui semblait ce qui semblait logique
j'ai envie de dire puisqu'on pensait que
les écailles et les poils étaient deux
structures différentes en réalité ce
n'est pas le cas et cahiers poils sont
en brio logiquement issus de la même
structure
donc c'est les écailles qui se sont
transformés en poids là bas
et ça ça fait ça aurait plus de sens
avec le registre fossile que je vous ai
montré tout à l'heure c'est à dire
d'abord des écailles puis la peau nue
puis des poils mais évidemment c'est pas
avec un registre fossile comme ça qu'on
peut tirer des conclusions mais ce
serait plus cohérent puisque si on avait
un scénario évolutif où il y avait
d'abord d eca et puis des écailles et
des poils pluie des puits juste des
poils bas à quel moment est ce qu'on à
quel endroit est ce qu on insère notre
liste rose aux russes à la peau nue
voyez donc là il faudrait faudrait faire
l'hypothèse que dans ce cas les listes
roseaux russe à la peau nue il aurait
non seulement perdu ses écailles mais
aussi ses poils avant de fossilisé bon
alors perdre ses poils je suis d'accord
mais alors perdre les écailles en
fossilisés et quand même conservé
l'empreinte de la peau ça fait beaucoup
d'hypothèses
ça fait beaucoup d'hypothèses donc cette
hypothèse là elle est beaucoup plus
intéressante elle est beaucoup plus
facile à comprendre
enfin nous aide beaucoup plus facilement
un comprendre le registre fossile qu'on
a devant les yeux en tout cas pour
l'instant
donc voilà c'est justement là je vous en
parlais donc notre liste rose or ici si
à la peau nue là est beaucoup plus
facile à interpréter dans ce contexte là
que dans un contexte où il faudrait une
coexistence des poils et des écailles
ce qui est totalement contraire à ce
qu'on voit là et puis il ya les
moustaches les fameuse moustache
alors si vous êtes à paléo artistes des
mammifères en fin d'été rapide
vous avez certainement pris l'habitude
de représentés votez rapide au mois avec
des moustaches pas forcément avec de la
fourrure mais au moins avec des
moustaches
vous êtes vous posé la question pourquoi
est ce que vous imiter un autre palais
aux artistes est-ce que vous est ce que
c'est parce que c'est des thérapies dès
que les thérapies dites c'est avec des
moustaches et un point c'est tout ou
bien est ce que c'est juste pour rendre
vos terres apside un peu plus
ressemblant à des mammifères ou bien
avaient voulu la littérature
scientifique pour dire que c'était
rapide avec des moustaches mon jeu
vous oblige pas à choisir un camp
maintenant mais voilà réfléchissez à
pourquoi vous imaginez si vous n'êtes
pas allé aux artistes pourquoi vous
imaginez que voter rapide avec des
moustaches donc il faut se poser la
question en fait à quoi servent les
moustaches les moustaches elles servent
comme vous le voyez alors ils appellent
ça les anglais appellent ça oui ce king
donc ça veut dire c'est prendre le mot
pour moustache qui s'appelle whiskers et
en faire un verbe donc ils moustache is
ils sont en train de moustache is et
donc la moustache isation ça consiste à
bouger les muscles qui sont en dessous
des moustaches pour utiliser les
moustaches à ce qu'elles font de mieux
c'est-à-dire organes tactile
orientations et reconnaissance voilà
donc les moustaches c'est un organe
tactile qui gagne sa valeur à être
mobiles avoir des moustaches fixe ça
sert pas à grand chose ça sert pas à
grand chose ou alors il faut compenser
en bougeant la tête mais globalement
avoir des moustaches fixe surtout si on
est un petit mammifère nocturne du
mésozoïque ça vous servirait pas à grand
chose l'intérêt d'avoir des moustaches
c'est de les bouger et dans la
littérature scientifique on a cette idée
extrêmement persistante que les petites
routes qu'on voit sur tous les crânes de
thérapie delà tous ces petits trous là
bas ils servaient à enraciner des
moustaches
donc ça c'est issu d'un article d'un
livre pardon qui est sorti en 2014 je
crois donc vous voyez le scientifique a
planté des fausses moustaches dans les
petits trous dans les petites roues du
crâne pour montrer comment les
moustaches était orienté ça ça date de
2018 ça vient de you're in her fiche
donc le poisson en vous un documentaire
avec neil cabinet et rodgers mis ce jour
là aussi ils reprennent cette idée que
les petits trous servait d'enracinement
pour les moustaches et cette idée est on
ne peut plus fausse allez on ne peut
plus fausse tout simplement parce que
les reptiles tels que ceux tyrannosaure
avait des moustaches
si vous partez du principe que ces
petits trous servait à enraciner des
moustaches
bah oui alors vous voyez il ya une belle
belle série de petits trous là dans
notre entre tyrannosaure est ce que ces
petits trous servait aussi à enraciner
des moustaches je ne crois pas et puis
de toute façon là des reptiles moderne
où on a les mêmes petits trous et il n'y
a pas de moustache dessus
donc quand on voit un petit crâne de
terra psid bas et qu'on voit ces petits
trous en fait il devait pas y avoir de
moustache c'est au contraire un
indicateur d'absence de moustache d'une
par comparaison avec les reptiles
moderne puisque les reptiles moderne qui
ont les mêmes petites routes n'ont pas
de moustache et de deux
tout simplement parce que ces petits
trous ils sont directement dans l'os
donc impossibilité totale de bouger les
moustaches
dans ce cas là pour une simple raison
c'est que le nerf qu'il est qui aurait
énervé les moustaches qui se serait
situé dans ces trous donc c'est le tube
vert que j'ai représenté ici sur cette
image qui va apparaître voilà ce nerf
qui s'appelle le nerf trijumeau il est
coincé dans l'os il est à l'intérieur de
l'os maxillaire il peut pas bouger
donc il ya aucune possibilité de
mouvement et on n'a pas non plus de
surface d'insertion pour les muscles qui
aurait permis de bouger les moustaches
donc en faites vous
si on continue à imaginer qu'il y avait
des moustaches et ben ses moustaches
n'aurait pas pu bouger et comme je
voulais dire les moustaches ça sert à
bouger le mieux pour une moustache c'est
de bouger alors il ya quelques
mammifères aujourd'hui qu'ils ont des
moustaches qui sont relativement
immobile mais c'est pas les mammifères
nocturnes
c'est pas les petits mammifères
nocturnes dont la vie dépend de leur
capacité à s'orienter avec leurs
moustaches et donc quand on suit
l'évolution de ce canal eh bien on se
rend compte que ce canal en fait ils
dégénère chez les ch et les synodaux
notamment chez les pros benmouna tient
encore une fois ceux qui ont donné les
manies faire ce canal selon k naan il
dégénère il devient de plus en plus
petits jusqu'à se transformer en un
foramen un simple foramen qui s'appelle
le foramen infra orbitaire et se fera
mais n'offrant orbitaire c'est le trou
que vous avez en dessous de l'oeil
le nerf passe dans ce trou se ramifie
dans vos joues et vosges où elles sont
capables de bouger
bon nous on n'a pas de moustache
mais si vous aviez des moustaches si
vous étiez une souris bas c'est la ramie
c'est le fait que ce que ce nerf se
ramifie dans les jouets non plus dans
l'os comme il le fait chez les sino dont
tu plus primitif que les pro b nominal
j'entends c'est le fait que c'est que ce
nerf se ramifie dans la chair et non
plus dans l'eau ce qui fait que vous
êtes capable de bouger de bouger les
muscles de votre face parce que le nerf
est libre à l'intérieur de la chair et
il ya aussi les surfaces d'insertion
musculaire pour les muscles pour les
muscles des lèvres et des joues qui
permettent de bouger ses moustaches
ces surfaces d'insertion musculaire
elles sont très importantes aussi dans
le fait de reconstituer la présence de
moustache ou pas chez nos pros baignade
donc les problèmes venaient attelé plus
dérivés les plus proches des mammifères
avait certainement des moustaches et la
capacité de moustache ise de l'est de
les bouger de bouger leurs moustaches
alors que les les les signaux de plus
base aux oeufs et les autres thérapies
s'il n'avait probablement pas de
moustache parce qu'il n'aurait pas eu la
capacité de les bouger du tout on peut
s'imaginer un monde où il avait des
moustaches et qu'ils n'étaient pas
capables de les bouger falloir expliquer
à quoi cela aurait servi si les s'ils
vivaient en plein jour et qu'il n'avait
pas besoin vraiment de moustache et
qu'il pouvait de toute façon pas les
bouger va falloir m'expliquer à quoi
cela aurait servi mais mais voilà là on
a une adaptation à la nocturne alité la
capacité d'avoir des moustaches et de
pouvoir s'orienter grâce aux moustaches
pendant la nuit et cette capacité
l'évolution de cette capacité tels que
reconstruite par la réduction du canal
infra orbitaire est là et du coup la
ramification du coeur d'une ère dans la
chair est complètement cohérente avec la
transition vers le goulet d'étranglement
dr on a une image qui est complètement
cohérente de des mammifères des
mammifères qui évolue tandis que les
dinosaures sont en train de se
développer à la fin du trias les
dinosaures sont en train de dominer de
commencé à dominer le monde
les mammifères sont en train
d'apparaître et sont en train de cons
rires la niche écologique de petites
bêtes nocturne de petit insectivore
nocturne et leur et on voit leur cerveau
s'adapte et développer des bulbes
olfactifs on voit leurs oreilles
développer une coquelet et on voit leur
museau se développer des moustaches
voilà ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'il n'y
avait pas forcément de poil avant un
évidemment il est possible qu'il y ait
eu des poils avant mais en général on
admet quand même plutôt que c'est la
fonction tactile qui a précédé la
fonction de thermorégulation chez l'été
rapide mais bon ça c'est c'est plus un
argument brio logique les poils se
développe avant les moustaches se
développe avant le reste de la fourrure
chez l'embryon est ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant c'est de constater que
l'évolution des poils
elle est corrélée à celle de l'évolution
de la lactation
d'une part parce que msx2 le fameux gène
msx2 quand vous le voulez désactiver
vous désactivez aussi les glandes
mammaires
donc ça désactive non seulement les
poils mais ça désactiver aussi les
grains lafabrie enfin le l'embryogénèse
des glandes mammaires
donc on a pas on finit avec les mutants
msx2 n'ont ni poil ni glande mammaire
donc déjà c'est la premier lien entre
les poêler les glandes mammaires et le
deuxième lien entre les poêler les
glandes mammaires bas c'est tout
simplement que les glandes mammaires à
la base sont intimement l'évolution
l'origine évolutive des glandes
mammaires est intimement reliée à celle
des poils on voit ça chez
l'ornithorynque donc chez leurs nids
thorax il n'y a pas de téton est en fait
les glandes mammaires sont directement
attaché au poil ce sont juste des
glandes à sueur des glandes sudoripares
donc c'est techniquement c'est les
glandes apocrines parce que vous avez
deux types de glandes vous avez vous
avez les glandes à ces baumes je crois
et vous avez les glandes endocrines bref
vous avez deux types de glander ce sont
des glandes
ce sont des glandes apocrines qui vont
sécréter qui sont transformés et qui
sécrètent le lait chez les mots notres m
et on a tout au long de l'évolution des
mammifères une association étroite entre
les poils et les glandes apocrines donc
les mots notres m comme vous le voyez on
les glandes allait les glandes mammaires
qui sont directement attaché au poêle
non pardon les les glandes mammaires ce
sont celles là
excusez-moi anvers donc vous avez ici
les glandes mammaires qui sont
directement rattachés au poil et le lait
coule le long des poils est en fait le
petit est les poils sa forme des genres
de dreadlocks de poils c'est délicieux
et donc ils tètent les dreadlocks de
poils chez les marsupiaux
vous avez en tout cas les marsupiaux les
plus basses eaux comme les opossums vous
avez toujours une association étroite
entre le téton parce que là il ya un
téton mais les tétons ont des poils en
fait chez les marsupiaux et après chez
les mammifères placentaires là par
contre vous avez dissociation des poils
et des glandes mammaires
vous pouvez avoir des poils autour des
glandes mammaires vous n'aurez pas des
poils directement à la sortie de la
glande mammaire comme ça se fait chez
les marsupiaux par exemple donc
l'association entre les poils et la
glande mammaire même si elle est plus
évidente aujourd'hui chez les
placentaire et très évidente chez les
marsupiaux et les mots notres m donc
voilà c'est la stimulation en fait de
ses poils qui déclenche la sécrétion de
l'est et on sait que et on sait que le
lait est issue justement delà de la
transformation de ces glandes apocrines
comme vous voyez ici est que le contenu
du lait en lui même est directement
dérivé en fait du mucus qui était
sécrétée par les glandes apocrines donc
les zélés les composants du mucus de ces
glandes apocrines donc qu'ils étaient
sécrétée par ces glandes les glandes à
la base du poil associés aux glandes à
sueur ce mucus
en fait les composantes ce mucus a été
retransmis remet en d'autres composants
d'autres protéines qu'on retrouve dans
le lait avec en plus d'autres protéines
venue du sang qui alimentent ces glandes
et tout ça ça vient en addition de
l'évolution des du palais secondaire
puisque la lactation n'est possible que
si vous êtes capable de faire
un mouvement de pompes avec votre langue
et ce mouvement de pompes avec votre
langue n'est possible que parce que vous
avez un palais secondaire qui c'est par
votre cabinet nasale de votre bouche
donc l'évolution du palais secondaire en
soi un palais secondaire peut servir à
plein d'autres trucs même les crocodiles
on appose un palais secondaire content
il n'allait pas je veux dire donc un
palais secondaire ça peut servir à plein
d'autres choses mais la présence d'un
palais secondaire est une condition
nécessaire à la lactation donc ouais
c'est juste pour vous dire c'est juste
pour que vous vous représentiez à quel
point l'évolution des poils est relié à
plein d'autres choses chez les
mammifères s'est relié au foramen
pinéale c'est relié à l'histologie de
l'os c'est relié à la géochimie l'os
c'est relié alors dotée remis à
l'évolution du lait le lait lui même et
veut est liée à l'évolution du palais
secondaire qui est lui même lié à la
façon dont on mâche la nourriture qui
est lui-même relié à l'évolution des
muscles de la face puisque le veau joue
là ce sont des muscles master 1 les
muscles zygomatiques et donc c'est ce
qui permet de hobo l'alimentaire de
rester dans votre bouche quand vous
mastiquer autrement tous barrés sur les
côtés si vous avez une bouche de
crocodiles donc tous barrés sur les
côtés quand vous mastiquer donc tous à
tous ces caractères là ils sont liés
entre eux et récemment donc sa gelée
rajouter vraiment jeu juste à la fin
c'est la découverte de ce cayenne ta
terium qui est un signe aux dons dérivés
un pro b nomination et se caille nta
terium il a été redécouvert en présence
de petits et donc là déjà on a une
première un premier indice donc l'os
enfin le fossile c'est ça donc vous
voyez ici une vertèbre de l'adulte
cahier matériaux mais chaque petite
tache de couleur là c'est un petit crâne
d'un d'un bébé caliente à terium donc
évidemment c'est pas c'est pas hyper
joly c'est pour ça que je vous ai mis
cette image là mais chaque petite tache
de couleur lacées un bébé caliente
intérieur donc la première chose c'est
que déjà l'association de l'adulte avec
le jeu avec les juvéniles ça suggère
sassus enfin là pour le coup c'est des
juvéniles
qu'on appelle périnataux c'est à dire
soit juste avant soit juste après la
naissance
donc ça suggère si caliente à terium
pour dde ça veut ça suggère couvaison si
caliente intérieur de pont n'est pas
neuf ça suggère soit parentaux donc
c'est c'est quoi qu'il arrive c'est
intéressant ça serait très intéressant 6
a suggéré couvaison et en l'occurrence
il y à 32 petit et 32 petits c'est très
très loin au dessus du nombre de bébés
qu'on les mammifères qui ne pondent pas
d'oeufs dans toute façon même les
mammifères qui pondent des oeufs en
l'occurrence nempont ne pas tant que ça
mais 32 petits c'est un chiffre normal
pour un reptile qui pond des oeufs c'est
un chiffre très très anormal pour un
mammifère qui n'en font pas voilà donc
ça suggère très fortement le nombre de
petits la suggère très fortement que
cayenne materion pont dde
donc ça suggère la couvaison donc ça
suggère un métabolisme à sang chaud
c'est intéressant aussi de se poser la
question de savoir si les ces mammifères
pour dde ou pas mais il est très très
fort probable que caliente à terium pont
dde puisque de toute façon les mots
notres aime encore aujourd'hui qu'ils
sont plus dérivés que canada terium
pompe d eux aussi donc il est fort
probable que caliente à terium pont dde
et que tous ces petits étaient été couvé
du coup par caliente intérieur ça pose
aussi la question du lait du coup eux
parce que 32 petit ça fait beaucoup à
l'été ça fait beaucoup de monde à elle
était donc il est fort probable que
caliente à therion ne l'était pas c'est
petit ce qui va du coup à l'encontre du
scénario msx2 voilà comme je vous le
disais les preuves sont contradictoires
les preuves sont très très très
contradictoires du coup puisque la
mutation des mets 6 2
kayhan ta terium n'a pas de fort amène
pinéale donc on s'attend pas à ce que on
s'attend à ce que le caliente à terium
et était capable d'allaiter du coup hors
32 petits c'est beaucoup trop de petits
à allaiter et on sait que caliente à
terium ne devait pas elle était de toute
façon parce que les petits ont déjà des
dents donc ils sont déjà capables de se
nourrir par eux mêmes donc on est on est
peut-être même sur une espèce midi
donc bref donc les preuves sont
contradictoires et les preuves sont
fortement reliées les unes aux autres et
c'est là où je veux en venir c'est que
les preuves sont toutes liées les unes
aux autres d'une façon ou d'une autre et
les preuves sont toutes contradictoires
les unes avec les autres
tout et tout est connecté la petite
taille et lyall endothermique y allait
même est liée à l'évolution du poil qui
elle même est liée à l'évolution du lait
qui est liée à la perte du foramen
pinéale qui est liée à la nocturne a dit
et qui est liée à l'évolution du cerveau
à la perte de la vision des couleurs le
l'évolution de la lactation ailier aller
au palais secondaire qui est lui-même
les à la mastication qui est donc lié à
l'évolution des muscles mastic ateurs et
à côté de ça vous avez l'évolution du
diaphragme et donc de la delà du
métabolisme de la façon dont enfin kelly
à l'évolution du diaphragme qui est lié
du coup à la respiration qui est liée à
la posture comme je voulais présenter au
début qui est aussi liée à la lande au
ter me bref tout absolument tout est lié
les uns aux autres et c'est extrêmement
difficile de trouver un signe dans de
thermique qui soit 100 % de termes y
voilà c'est là où je veux en venir
et c'est peut-être pour ça que tous les
signaux sont contradictoires c'est parce
que les deux termes is a peut-être été
un processus pas à pas ou chaque petit
changement dans chacun de ces caractères
que je viens d'énumérer chaque petit
que je viens d'énumérer conduisait à un
autre changement dans un autre caractère
et ainsi de suite dans une cascade un
fini de causer de conséquences qui au
final 10 en finale qui au final a
conduit à l'endos thermique on connaît
aujourd'hui chez les mammifères qui
n'est pas si simple que ça au final
parce qu'il ya aussi ça c'est que j'ai
beaucoup simplifié le concept d'en doter
remis chez les mammifères
landau thermiques chez les mammifères en
elle-même n'est pas si simple que ça il
ya les mots notres m notamment ou pas la
même en de thermique les placentaire et
les marsupiaux quoi donc même ça c'est
pas si simple et même ça c'est toujours
en cours d'évolution j'ai envie de dire
donc voilà il faut pas six
ginel endothermique comme étant juste un
bouton compteur ne contournent sonné 9,1
voilà c'est pas un bouton sur lequel on
appuie et pouf on est en de termes et
puis on aura pu tuer pouf on ectothermes
tendance et c'est une spirale de causer
de conséquences et du coup c'est pas
surprenant que on constate des preuves
contradictoires sur l'origine de landau
termine c'est fort probable que les
poils est évolué d'abord dans un rôle
sensorielle donc les moustaches que la
posture érigé ça a favorisé la chasse
avant tout et pas tellement le la
respiration et puis que vous ayez eu bas
et que vous ayez eue par dessus ça le
nocturne le bottleneck qui a changé tout
ce qui est les organes des sens qui vous
fait augmenter la taille du cerveau qui
on a lui-même réchauffer un petit peu le
sens et vous avez l'évolution de la
mastication qui a augmenté la
la quantité d'énergie que vous pouviez
extraire de votre votre bol alimentaire
et cette évolution de la mastication du
coup elle alimente finalement la
machinerie cellulaire qui permet de
produire aussi plus d'énergie mais cette
évolution de la mastication conduit
aussi à l'évolution du palais secondaire
qui conduit qui permet elle même de le
mouvement de pompes qui permet la
lactation enfin bref et le foramen
pinéale qui qui évoluent en fonction de
si vous êtes de 10 heures nocturnes et
qui évolue aussi en fonction de si vous
êtes en de termes ou ectothermes et qui
a lui-même qui lui même influencé
génétiquement par des mêmes facteurs
génétiques qui influencent l'évolution
des poils et de l'eau voilà c'est pas
juste
en d'autres termes ectothermes c'est ça
le truc
et voilà et ça encore c'est la version
simplifiée voilà la version qui a été
publié en 2005 par kent
voilà un chercheur qui s'appelle kiev à
l'aller elle commet tous les facteurs
influencent les uns les autres et donc
on a certainement une évolution de
landau thermiques chez les mammifères
enfin celle été rapide qui a été très
lente
alors qui a peut-être été kickstart et
par la limite permise atria ski c'est
comme le suggèrent les études paléo
histologique et et géochimiques vous
allez peut-être us cet événement qui
dans un terreau fertile pour l'évolution
de landau termine à a arrêté finalement
le coup de pied au cul qui a permis à
l'endos permis d'émerger
et puis après vous avez toute cette
machinerie là qui s'est mis en branle et
qui a petit à petit fait apparaître
landau thermie telle qu'on la connaît
chez les mammifères et comme j'ai dit il
ya pas qu une endothermique chez les
mammifères donc en plus c'est paul c'est
pas facile à comprendre et c'est aussi
la raison pour laquelle je ne fais plus
secours à metz étudiants c'est parce que
ce bordel là ils ne comprennent pas et
je ne m'attends pas moi même je serai
très
je resterai un blanc disant que j'ai une
vague idée j'ai une vague idée de la
quel point ça devait être le bordel mais
honnêtement je vais pas aller jusqu'à
dire que je comprends ce bordel g unit
j'ai une idée de à quel point ce bordel
et intrigué et voilà donc c'est comme je
le dis c'est une fin de cours assez
frustrante de vous dire que on ne le
sait pas quand l'an ii termine a évolué
et c'est probablement pas un événement
c'est probablement des centaines de
milliers de petits événements qui ont eu
lieu
génération après génération millions
d'années après millions d'années qui ont
conduit à ce qu'on appelle landau ternie
voilà j'espère que ça vous a éclairés
sur l'état des connaissances actuelles
parce que là c'est plus un état des
connaissances actuelles qu'un réel cours
au final c'est c'est à dire que c'est un
état des connaissances actuelles mais
aussi de ce qu'on ne connaît pas et de
choses qu'on ne connaîtra aussi
probablement jamais mais on espère quand
même un jour faire des découvertes qui
permettront quand même de mettre un
petit peu de lumière dans toute cette
obscurité
mais en attendant je vous dis à la
prochaine merci beaucoup